und der bundesgesundheitsminister ist
unseres berlin zugeschaltet guten abend
herr spahn und russland wenn man lockt
hat will man ja eigentlich eine
möglichst aktuelle und korrekte zahlen
basis haben und zu entscheiden
dafür muss die richtigen getestet werden
dafür muss schnell gemeldet werden daran
hapert es aber immer noch
es hapert an bestimmten stellen ja aber
das arbeiten auch viele öffentliche
gesundheitsämter im moment mit viel viel
engagement und einsatz
wir müssen sehen wie sie seit vielen
wochen ja auch jedes wochenende viele
überstunden im ständigen einsatz aber
eins ist ganz wichtig wenn wir jetzt es
geschafft haben gemeinsam auch die zahl
der neuinfektionen so unterzubringen
richtung 3 4000 am tag dann muss es uns
auch gelingen dort zu bleiben
nur dann können wir schrittweise ja
zurück in eine neue normalität und das
gelingt nur mit gesundheitsämtern die in
der lage sind sehr schnell bei jedem
infizierten auch alle kontakte der
letzten tage nachzuvollziehen und vor
allem dann auch diese zu kontaktieren
und aufzufordern zu hause zu bleiben
damit für infektionsketten ganz schnell
unterbrechen
und dafür braucht es eben gut
ausgestattete öffentliche
gesundheitsämter in den kreisen und
städten aber bei drei 4009 infektionen
am tag ist das realistisch dass man da
bei jedem einzelnen mit gruppen von
mitarbeitern des gesundheitsamtes dann
die kontakte alle nach volk sieht und
diese ganzen gespräche auch dazu führt
die da notwendig sind wir haben ja knapp
400 gesundheitsämter in deutschland die
sind natürlich unterschiedlich stark
betroffen
aber die allermeisten gesundheitsämter
hatten in der letzten woche weniger als
100 neuinfektionen in der woche nach zu
verfolgen
das ist aufwand aber das geht aber es
geht natürlich noch leichter auch mit
der richtigen technischen ausstattung
deswegen wollen wir auch ein
förderprogramm machen
von bis zu 150000 euro pro öffentlichen
gesundheitsdienst von seiten des bundes
damit sie sich weiter digitalisieren
können ihre mitarbeiter ausstatten
können damit meldewege im übrigen auch
digital und schneller laufen und damit
wir dann auch möglicherweise apps eben
nutzen können zur unterstützung sowohl
bei der kontrolle der quarantäne
auch da wird ja heute angerufen oder
vorbeigefahren das geht natürlich auch
theoretisch per app und das wird gerade
entwickelt oder beim nachvollziehen der
kontakte bisher ist aber noch so dass
viele gesundheitsämter per fax arbeiten
im jahre 2020 das gibt es das stimmt
vereinzelt auch noch es gibt auch schon
viele dieses digital machen aber eben
auch noch viele die durchaus investition
in dem bereich gebrauchen können und die
wahrheit ist das muss man aussagen
slomka der öffentliche gesundheitsdienst
das öffentliche gesundheitswesen ist in
den letzten jahren nicht immer so
auch mit der aufmerksamkeit versehen
worden die es verdient hätte offenkundig
verdient hätte wie wir in dieser krise
gemeinsam lernen und das müssen und
wollen wir jetzt schnell nachholen bund
und länder haben schon vereinbart und
die länder haben auch schon begonnen
die gesundheitsämter vor ort personell
zu stärken wir wollen sie ihm auch
digital steht wann soll denn diese
stichwort digital diese app kommen
eigentlich war davon ursprünglich mal
die rede ende april bis man
realistischerweise ist die da die app
zur kontakt nachverfolgung da wo man ja
heute immer auch aus der erinnerung
heraus nachfragt das händisch macht die
soll im laufe des mais kommen das ist
unser ziel ist nur eines wichtig frau
slomka das muss natürlich bei der bei
der datensicherheit also die frage ob es
gehackt werden kann oder nicht beim
datenschutz also bei der frage wer hat
zugriff auf die daten und auch vom
konzept wissenschaftlich dahinter ja
auch alles passen das muss gerade bei
datenschutz und datensicherheit
möglichst perfekt sein
dann bevor wir starten können es geht
hier um sensible bewegungsdaten und
deswegen wollen wir das jetzt eben auch
weiter mit der nötigen intensität mit
dem nötigen engagement aber auch
gründlichkeit vorantreiben sie sagen
selbst wir wollen jetzt nicht wieder in
boddin reproduktions faktor 1 kommen
das bedeutet aber man hält jetzt an
dieser strategie gedümpelt so rundum 1
mal ein bisschen weniger und wenn es
dann etwas mehr wird dann muss man
wieder einen lock down rein also das
machen wir jetzt im prinzip ist es ein
wunder medikament oder impfstoff gibt
also noch ein jahr oder anderthalb oder
sogar zwei jahre
es gibt neben diesem punkt eher dieser
zahl der reproduktionsrate natürlich
auch noch die wichtige frage wie hoch
ist die absolute zahl der neuinfektionen
am tag da haben wir eben dass auch
gemeinsam ist ja geschafft auf einen
niedrigen stand zu bringen und natürlich
die frage was kann das gesundheitswesen
leisten etwa wie viele intensiv
kapazitäten stehen zur verfügung aber
ich sage noch einmal alle drei ziele
erreichen wir nur wenn wir sehr sehr
schnell jeden neu infizierten
identifizieren also gut es
und wenn wir dann sehr sehr schnell alle
kontakte auch ausfindig machen und
auffordern können auch für zwei wochen
zu hause zu bleiben das ist im kern der
schlüssel bei einer solchen infektionen
beim solche infektiösen virus wie diesen
alle kontakte sehr schnell zu erreichen
aber der jetzt diese lockerungen dazu
führen sollten das dann doch eine zu
große zahl von bürgern das gefühl hat
naja ist jetzt alles wieder normal
und dann steigen die zahlen wieder dann
wird man das ja wieder einfangen müssen
also geht man dann wieder einen
richtigen lockdown rein und daran dass
jetzt restaurants konzerte und so wieder
öffnen ist eigentlich auf ganz lange
sicht nicht mehr zu rechnen was ganz
entscheidend sein wird für uns alle ist
dass wir bestimmte dinge im alltag und
zwar jederzeit er gemeinsam einhalten
und auch immer besser üben denn das
spürt jeder von uns müssen sie auch üben
weil sie nicht direkt angelegt sind also
eineinhalb meter abstand halten wenn es
eben geht händehygiene intensiv die
hände waschen idealerweise mehrfach am
tag oder auch da wo es mal länger wird
etwa im öffentlichen personennahverkehr
man das machen wird man brauche auch
eine perspektive und wenn man bei dieser
r1 strategie hält dann gegen ist alltag
jahre oder so bis ein impfstoff geprägt
bis es einen impfstoff gibt werden wir
miteinander und aufeinander aufpassen
müssen gerade auch auf die älteren die
hochbetagten die chronisch kranken die
eine risikogruppe ja leider sind für
dieses virus dort besonders hart müssen
wir leidvoll erleben in manche
einrichtungen ist auch zuschlägt und das
heißt aufeinander aufpassen das heißt ja
über monate etwas abstand angeht was
hygiene angeht was auch alltags masken
im alltag angeht etwa in der u bahn oder
im bus wird das eben diese neue
normalität sein von der wir ja auch
reden so wie vorher wird es erst wieder
sein können wenn es tatsächlich einen
impfstoff gibt ersparen
danke für das interview gerne